على الرغم من انها باهظه الثمن مقارنه
بنظائرها الا ان المجوهرات مجوهرات
الماركات التجاريه الفاخره تحظى لاقبال
واسع طبعا يمشي
مليونيريه وباهضه واحنا غاليين وما بيطلع
لنا الا الغالي
مشاهدينا عندما ترى المشاهير المفضلين
لديك يرتدون هذه المجوهرات المميزه
بتصميماتها العصريه وجوده صناعتها دائما
طبعا وخصوصا النساء يكونوا بدهم يقتنوا كل
هذه
المجوهرات لكن اذا قارنتها بمجوهرات اخرى
من نفس الوزن والعيار والقراض ستجد الفارق
في السعر كبير جدا كيف
كيف لا فانت لا تشتري القطعه فقط بل تشتري
الاسم ايضا ويمكن الاسم سيكون ثمنه باهظ
اكثر من القطعه نفسها على كل حال يعادل
سوار ناعم وبسيط جدا من احد هذه الماركات
قد يتجاوز سعر الخمس عشر الفعل وبعد هذه
العلامات التجاريه تحتفظ بقيمتها بل
وترتفع اسعارها فهل يعد شراء مجوهرات
العلامات التجاريه الفاخره استثمارا مجديا
وناجحا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا الخبيره
الاقتصاديه عمر بكير عمر صباح الخير صباح
الخير يا اهلا وسهلا
فتحت علينا موضوع صعب يا اخي طيب خلينا
قبل لا ندخل بتفاصيل اليوم اللي هو هذا
انا ما راح اقول الماركه لكن هو عباره عن
مسمار
بشكل معين يوضع على اليد
التقليد منه الذهب الذهب بسعر غالي فما
بالك وهو يحمل اسم هذه المراه ليش الماركه
لها قيمه ولا المصنعيه ولا شنو
صح اولا يعني هاي الشركات تعبت على
البراند على اسم البراند تبعها فطبعا
بتلاقي الها بتلاقي الها بتلاقي الها
ملايين الدولارات
فبالتالي طبعا يعني حتى التقليد طبعا طبعا
يعني جزء من هاي التكلفه او جزء من سعرها
بكون عم بغطي الكوست للماركتينج للكامبينز
للبراندنج وهذا الشيء بياخذ مدار سنوات مش
اشهر او سنتين
الثمينه الذهب او الف
ضه القيمه يعني انه بدك تستثمر بدك تخبي
فلوس للمستقبل ممتاز انك تخبيهم او
تستثمرهم بقطع ذهبيه بالضبط ولكن اذا
كيف ممكن يكون قطعه ذهبيه اذا انا
اشتريتها من ماركه حقها 15 الف دولار
بينما الذهب اللي فيها فعليا ما بيسوى
اكثر من
ثلاث صحيح فهذه مش
منطقيا معناها مش مخزن جيد للقيمه والثمن
بكل تاكيد هلا طبعا حتى الذهب بشكل عام
ننسى شويه ذهب بشكل عام هو الفضه هو مخزن
للقيمه ولكن هذا مثل ما عم نشوف نحن
بالاسواق العالميه عم بكون في تدبدب
بالسعر ممكن يطلع ممكن يهبط ببعض الفترات
فطبعا كله في عليه
كله في عليه ريسك ولكن لما نحن عم نقلد
براند عالمي عم نصنع منه يمكن الحق الذهب
اللي فيه بيطلع 10% من القيمه الموجوده
الفعليه فيه فبالتالي ولكن هي فكره
التقليد او الشكل اللي انت عم تلبسه مشان
هيك المقلد سواء حيكون صانع او حرفي او
حتى يمكن شركه عم بتحاول تقلد هذه النوع
من البراند اجباري بدها تاخذ على المصنعيه
بدها تاخذ على تكلفه تقليد العالي الدقه
اللي عم نشوفه حاليا بالسوق طيب اليوم اذا
مقرنا هذه القطعه اذا رحنا الى المجوهرات
الالماس مثلا اقل من الذهب احيانا
باعاده بيعه في الاونه الاخيره حتى الساعه
يمكن في العقد الاخير فقط ارتفع سوق
الساعات لكن قبل ذلك كان ايضا
رخيصه ما تنباع بهذا هل هو استثمار جيد
اني انا اشتري هذه القطعه المميزه من هذه
الماركه المميزه واحتفظ فيها لسنوات قادمه
طبعا هلا هذا الشيء هذا الجواب يعتمد على
الاشخاص ذات نفسهم ليش لانه في كثير من
الاشخاص بيشتروا هاي الساعات لانه عندهم
شغف لالها مش بس فقط كاستثمار بيكون
في ناس استثمار صح في تجار بيعرفوا كيف
بيشتغلوها فبتلاقي عم بيحاولوا يجمعهم قدر
من الساعات او حتى الساكس من مختلف
البراندات لحتى ينطروا على سعرها بعد فتره
بيرجعوها ولكن فعليا حسب بيرجع هذا
للمستثمر ثروتي يعني اشتري
عمر انا انا بدي هيك جواب نهائي في حال
انه انا اشتريت قطعه ذهب من ماركه معينه
ودفعت حقها يعني غالي بعد عشر سنين بدي
ابيعها هل كان افضل اني اشتري نفس الذهب
نفس وزن الذهب نفس كميه الذهب ولكن بدون
ماركه لا هل من الافضل كان من ناحيه لما
بدي اجي ابيعها ممكن تحافظ على سعرها يعني
القطعه اللي عليها مارك ممكن يرتفع سعرها
بشكل جدا ملحوظ ممكن تشتريها ويرتفع سعرها
وممكن تلاقي الذهب الفعلي اللي انت
اشتريتيه عم يرتفع اكثر بكثير من هاي
السلعه فبيرجع هذا الشيء للمستثمر ذات
نفسه او للمشتري بحسب يعني اذا انا عم
بشتري هاي لانه عندي شغف اني اجمعها
ولاحظت انه بعد 10 سنوات طلع سعرها بشكل
ملحوظ هذا من حظك هذا هذا خلص وقتنا
يدفعني اني انا اشتري القطعه خام مثلا
اشتري الالماس خام ولا اشتريها لماركه
معينه
وبالتالي من اني انا مستقبلا احسب حساب
انه هذا هذا الامر سيرتفع من ماركه معينه
في عندك
اعلى انه يكون ارتفاعها بعد كم سنه اكثر
من قطعه مصنعين اكثر من قطعه ليست قطعه
واحده اكيد في عندك اكثر من قطعه اكثر من
قديش بينزل لكل فترات ولكن بشكل عام
بزيد الفاليو تبعه شكرا جزيلا للخبير
الاقتصادي عمر بكير شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات